The army thought the experiment was a
failure but their drug didn't work but
it just took a little time to turn you
into Deathstroke
where's my boy where's Joseph will you
join hive or will my man slit little
Joseph's throat here and now
the answer is No
you're a mercenary
and the people that you love have paid a
terrible price
you see I have a secret
I'm a knight like the ones of our
favorite book
roaming a dangerous world and I don't
want those dragons to hurt you ever again
so what are we going to do about it
we you're not going after him alone this time
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Deathstroke movie
trailer video if you didn't realize they
stealth made a Deathstroke movie and
just dropped it video on demand because
of the virus not a lot of theatrical
release is happening it's a relatively
short movie - there's a bunch of Easter
eggs so we'll break it down also explain
what's going on with Deathstroke in the
movies and Deathstroke and other places
too because there are several
live-action versions of Deathstroke
right now if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with Deathstroke in the DC
movies as far as we know Joe Manganiello
is still Deathstroke in the DC movies
and they were planning on doing a
live-action Deathstroke movie with his
Justice League Deathstroke I will talk
about that during the video but this
movie right here is actually an r-rated
animated movie if you're surprised that
they're doing that they actually just
released Justice League apocalypse war
probably one of the best animated DC
movies that they've ever done and that
was rated R 2 so it sounds like Warner
Brothers is getting more and more
comfortable with doing r-rated animated
movies there have been other hard-core
r-rated animated movies in the past
they've done like Batman The Killing
Joke if you didn't recognize the voice
during that trailer Deathstroke is being
played by Michael Chiklis which isn't
something I ever expected it's kind of a
surprise but this is all just about
Deathstroke a little bit about his
origin story but it doesn't completely
retell his origin story it says he's
just a small part of it the movie itself
is relatively short it was originally
billed as a series and without giving
away big spoilers about the way that
they end it because they have had a
chance to see the movie they do have a
clear set up for a sequel or a season 2
or however they plan on handling that
for the most part hive is the main
villain
they tell his basic backstory explained
his family there are a couple minor
changes from the comics they don't do
Grant Wilson in Rose Wilson is now his
oldest child from an affair before he
had Joseph Jericho for the most part the
characters abilities are relatively
accurate of the comics but this movie is
mostly just setting up what's going on
with hive and with Jericho and with Rose
wilson ravager and big deep cut easter
egg the person who plays Billy
wintergreen during this is actually
Colin sallman who played Walter Steele
on arrow I know everyone
remembers Manu Bennett Sviridov arrow
it'd be amazing if they could bring him
back at some point on one of the TV
shows but because of what's happening
with Deathstroke in the DC movies and
because of what's happening with him on
Titans because there's another new
live-action version I don't know if
Manute is ever going to come back and
play the character again but Never Say
Never
what's happening with Deathstroke and
the movies right now is that they're
getting ready for the Justice League
Snider cut I just did a trailer video
for that yesterday Zack Snyder released
some new footage they're going to release
even more footage later this summer at
the DC fandom event Joe Manganiello
was actually tweeting out when he found
out that they were going to do this saying
that yeah they're going to put the original
post-credit scene back in from Justice
League in the theatrical cut he just
breaks Lex Luthor out of prison and then
they talk about forming the injustice
league a league of our own so to speak
so win the Justice League Snider cut it
just sounds like we're going to get way
more death stroke in that post-credit
scene or towards the end of the movie in
breaking Lex Luthor out of prison then
then discussing their plans about what's
going to happen next because clearly
they were trying to set up more of a
villain team-up down the road this
Deathstroke post-credit scene even in
the Snyder cut was also originally going
to set up a Deathstroke versus Batman
movie that was going to be Ben Affleck's
version of the Batman it was going to be
more of an Arkham Asylum type of movie
Batman fighting his way through each
level lower into Arkham and it was going
to be based on the raid redemption if
you haven't seen that movie is a great
martial arts action heavy movie
Deathstroke was going to be the main
villain of that then they also developed
a separate Deathstroke spin-off movie
just for him that would have gotten more
into his origin story so they had big
plans for Deathstroke in the DC movies
the director of the Deathstroke movie
said that that's mostly been
back-burnered so the scripts and all the
development for that is sitting on a
shelf right now they might revisit it at
some point later they haven't announced
any future release date for an actual
Deathstroke movie but I think because of
the success of the Joker movie and then
doing more hardcore villain r-rated DC
movies they might be more open to doing
a new Deathstroke live-action project
and I know a lot of you have asked about
this too because people are like what
about Ben Affleck coming back for an HBO
max Batman series if the Snyder cut
takes off I do think that if the Snyder
cut does well Warner Brothers will be
more open to doing HBO max projects like
the Snyder cut I don't think that Ben
Affleck is planning on coming back
the Batman but HBO max would be perfect
for a hardcore Deathstroke miniseries
you do six to eight episodes just like
the big Marvel Disney Plus series
that's basically what DC is using HBO
max for the Green Lantern HBO series is
going to be super big-budget in the Justice
League dark project that JJ Abrams is
doing on HBO max is going to be super
big-budget the reason why they're
putting those on HBO max and not doing
them as movies first is just because
they can spend more time doing the
storytelling they want more subscribers
for HBO max so they want to put premium
content there and they can make it a
little more hardcore a little more
r-rated remember that live-action
Deathstroke teaser that Ben Affleck
posted so many years ago
that wasn't actually for Justice League
that was actually for the Batman movie
that he was developing when they were
still trying to figure that out they did
try to do a relatively comic-book
accurate version of Deathstroke on the
Titans TV show there were a couple of
changes to the way they did his
character but they introduced him
through a Nightwing origin story about
Dick Grayson becoming the Nightwing
character and using Teen Titans the
Judas contract from the comics talking
about Deathstroke tear list where does
this new animated movie rank in the
other DC movies recently and with the
other versions of Deathstroke I feel
like they did a good job with a story
it's meant to be smaller self-contained
Michael Chiklis did a great job I'm
still partial to Manu Bennett spurgeon
and I still really really wanted to see
what Joe Manganiello was going to do
with the character I still think that
Justice League apocalypse war is
probably going to be DC's best animated
movie or best r-rated animated movie for
a good long while the upcoming movies
that they have right now are Batman the
long Halloween which I'm actually really
excited about because one it's a badass
story and I'm surprised that they
haven't tried to turn it into a movie
before but also this is kind of funny
because Matt Reeves the Batman movie
during 2021 is also based on the long
Halloween comic book story now just to
be clear it's only inspired by the long
Halloween comic book so it's not going to
be exactly like the comics story the
animated Batman long Halloween movie
will be much more comic-book accurate
albeit an abridged version of the comic
because the movies only going to be about
two hours long they're also doing a
brand new Superman man of tomorrow movie
it's sort of a refresh of the character
because they just used the Justice
League apocalypse war movie to sort of
end
this version of the Justice League DC
animated movie universe they had all
these movies going back to Justice
League war in the flash flashpoint
movies so many years ago that were all
in continuity with each other this
shared universe so the reason why they
rebooted that with Justice League
Apocalypse war is because they wanted to
give it their sort of Avengers infinity
war an Avengers endgame bookend
give them a chance to retool things
behind the scenes try some new animation
styles and some new techniques and just
start fresh with the new versions of the
characters and new voiceover actors
playing the characters but they'll
always bring back the classic voiceover
actors like Kevin Conroy to do more
Batman projects there's even rumors that
Bruce Timm mr. Batman and the animated
series himself is also coming back to do
another Batman project I know there's a
lot of questions about what's going to
happen with the Justice League Snyder
cut is that going to be canon now are
they going to do new projects set in
that universe going forward technically
everything stays canon the universe
continues as long as the same actors are
playing the characters even if it's only
a couple I know Robert Pattinson is
taking over as the Batman but there's
ways to explain stuff like that like the
flash in the flashpoint movie that's the
easiest way hands down to explain why
Batman looks different after the flash
movie there'll be a bunch of footage for
all the upcoming DC movies and panels
happening at the DC fan dome event later
this year if we get any more details
about stuff of course I'll do new videos
congratulations chase gaming you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here to rewatch that
Justice League Snyder cut trailer and
click here for my Justice League
apocalypse war ending and easter eggs
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!